lottie has three tickets in a raffle
just gonna jot that down
this is what is it question freddie
loddie
has three tickets lottie equals three
tickets that's the sum total of who she
is
uh there are 25 tickets in total and
two prizes so 25 tickets
total yes
of what oh you mean they're working oh
that one uh i'll come back i'll give you
like a neater version of that i promise
okay
but i'm okay with you taking a picture
all right and then it says drawer
probability tree now
i saw a bunch of you actually and i kind
of i was delighted looking at you all
around the um
around the room we got every version
right there are three numbers here there
are three numbers here and you've
already been told draw a probability
tree
so i saw some of you start off like this
and you were like
oh this is this is not going well right
so what what is this it's like oh i have
25 tickets
let's draw out 25 things and then you're
like no no that's a bad idea okay
so i'm not going to do that now you
might then think what about the three
right lottie's got three tickets start
drawing out like this
now there's a there's a logic behind
that right i've got three options there
there's just a teeny bit of a problem
what do like if i were to say
let's just let's just draw it out like
this as an example right
this is a a word that i haven't ever
seen formally used but i think you'll
know what i
mean when i show you the diagram here
right each i'm going to call them layer
each layer of the probability tree
represents
something right it represents something
happening so for example
if i said oh we're flipping coins or
rolling dice right
each layer of the probability tree would
be
um i flipped a coin right and then here
were all the things that could have
happened does that make sense like heads
or tails
or i i rolled the dice and then here are
all the things that could happen one two
three four
five six et cetera okay now if these two
represent different events
do three different things happen hello
she here uh no not today unfortunately
so
let them know he actually yeah just let
him know this way
thanks that's right see ya
okay
stay with me so each one's
an event right so you're in some trouble
here thinking about having
three branches not only does your
probability tree become very complicated
but it's not the clearest way to
represent what's happening
so here's what i'm going to suggest
instead
i just start off drawing two right what
do they represent
well for this this is i'm going to draw
the first prize
in this raffle right everyone have a
look at your ticket numbers i'm about to
draw first prize and we'll find out who
it is in the room
okay so lottie's looking she's got her
tickets in hand
right there's only two things that could
possibly happen right she either wins
that first prize
or she loses or she doesn't win okay so
let's think about the chance of
switching you can see me having drawn
these right
how many possibilities are there for her
to win on that first prize
she's got three of the tickets in her
hand and there are 25 being drawn out of
the bucket
right so that's where we get this three
out of 25 from does that make sense
okay then down the bottom here that's
just the what do we call this starts
with a c
it's the everything else that could
happen compliment very good
22. out of 25.
stay with me at 12 so from there right
that's the first prize and you can see i
think it's helpful
to actually call it that right um do you
have to
no but i'm just confused if i don't
actually label what's going on
and then the same thing happens again
right
when we're looking at the second prize
the first thing that i notice is the
sample space
has changed right for all of these
different things there are no longer 25
tickets
in the bucket right because one's been
taken out whoever won that
won either what he won or someone else
did right so everything here is going to
be out of 24
every single thing so i write down that
first
okay she still has the chance for
winning
or losing in each case and now i just
need to know how many tickets are left
in each category
okay uh let's go down to the first one
right
if she won the first time she's like oh
cool ticket number one it won
is that relevant to her winning again
well it can't be it's already been
pulled out right so therefore she only
has
two tickets left in her hand that could
still win
out of the 24 that are there right and
then of course you still have the
compliment
22 out of 24 there right if she didn't
win
the first time she you know some other
number person's number got called
she's got tickets one two and three in
her hand they could all still be winners
right
so that's why her possibility there is
three out of 24
um and then there's your compliment okay
so but then part b is probably your body
yes so where do i get this number from
okay and
it's true the answer itself doesn't tell
you very much right the question says
find the probability that lottie wins
the second
prize so do i care what happens to the
first prize
no no i do not right so therefore i can
consider both of these branches either
of them are fine
right so let's go up this first one
right
so if she wins the first prize
the probability of her winning the
second prize is um this one up here
right so this goes right back to the
first question right these two
probabilities here do i multiply them or
do i add them
i multiply i multiply because i need
them both to happen the first price has
to happen
has to be drawn and then the second
price is going to be drawn as well so
this guy here would be 3 out of 25
multiplied by 2 out of 24 is that okay
which equals what sorry um well
looks like it'll be 6 out of 600.
i think which is one percent right
but this this is not the whole deal
right this is just the probability that
she wins the first
and the second prize there's another way
for her to win the second prize
which is let's use a different color
right
she can lose the first prize right but
that's fine that's fine you guys told me
the first prize doesn't matter
and then she can win the second prize so
what's the probability of that
again i'm going to multiply it 22 out of
25
multiply by 3 out of 24.
that's 66 out of 600.
is that okay so now either of these are
fine
so you know how we multiplied to cross
to go across here
well i add to go down like so
so that gives me 72 out of 600 which i
hope
is 3 out of 25 thumbs up